pas une maladie l'asmo sexuelle tout
bien d'accord le dire
[Musique]
alors les terrains dont six à faire en
sorte que tous considèrent qu'être
homosexuels ou transsexuels est une
maladie qu'il faut guérir donc il ya
certains de assez ciblées qui sont
un peu sectaire certaines religions dans
certains milieux très intégristes on
pense qu'effectivement dis donc on
soigne son enfance son adolescence qui
ne soit pas homosexuel et qu'il ne soit
pas trop 500 pas la perdre c'est quelque
chose contre les qualifs côté parce que
évidemment c'est pas une maladie on en
guérit pas c'est un choix etc de poule
au pot c'est aussi pour protéger cette
ces gens là
[Musique]
ce texte va jusqu'à encore vous et
l'identité de genre mais chez moi je
fais partie de ces récompenses que
l'identité de genre c'est quoi ya pas de
définition nous nous subissons
aujourd'hui une idéologie permanence
qu'il vient des états unis
officiellement qui consiste à dire on
peut être ni homme ni femme
arrêtée alors d'abord je pense que c'est
dangereux parce qu'on finit par
amalgames et les homosexuels et les
transsexuels et l'identité de genre ça
n'a strictement rien à voir ça n'a
strictement rien à voir l'identité jean
cinq ans après n'arrive pas défini sauf
qu on subit on subit comme d'habitude
des pressions de minorités qui veulent
nous imposer leur point de vue là mais
pauvre en et far compet transsexuels
changé voilà ça sur le choix personnel
comment respecter mais arrêtez de mon
bras les dits nantis dédiant c'est pas
un concept défini ça perturbe le débat
et puis aujourd'hui il ya un public à
préserver ce sont les adolescents les
jeunes qui subissent ils subissent
énormément l'affluence des réseaux
sociaux il faut accompagner pouvoir si
voilà les questions qui se posent sont
des questions qui sont définitivement
pas parce que le choix est quand même
assez important pour la suite de sa vie
nous voilà ces pressions qui sont faites
par des lobbys de minorités elle est
insupportable depuis et aujourd'hui nous
devons préserver un certain nombre de
jours moment je veux faire supprimer en
tout cas à chaque fois que le mot terme
est cité je veux faire supprimer
identité de genre parce que ce n'est pas
assez